.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Warum werden Menschen kriminell?
Wie können wir sie
auf den richtigen Weg bringen?
Dieser Frage
gehe ich in dieser Sendung nach.
Einmal Täter, immer Täter?
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Ich bin in der Justizvollzugsanstalt
Thorberg im Emmental.
Im Käfig, im Knast, in der Kiste.
Hinter mir sitzen 180 Männer ein,
die eines gemeinsam haben:
Sie wurden alle straffällig.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Das ist Hans-Rudolf Schwarz,
der Direktor des Thorbergs.
Danke, dass wir hier sein dürfen.
Können Sie mir sagen, welche Menschen
bei Ihnen im Thorberg sind?
Das sind alles Straftäter, denen
eine Fluchtgefahr vorausgesagt wird.
Also eher die schweren Jungs.
- Ja.
Von welchen Delikten sprechen wir?
Vom Bankräuber bis zum Vergewaltiger
oder einem Verwahrten
haben wir hier alles.
Der Älteste ist 76,
der Jüngste 19.
Eine riesige Bandbreite.
Und insgesamt haben Sie
40 verschiedene Nationen hier drin.
Jawohl. 40 Nationen.
Und entsprechend
auch 20-30 verschiedene Sprachen.
Ja.
Ich muss zugeben, es macht Eindruck,
wenn man sich das anschaut.
Es ist
eine sehr spezielle Atmosphäre.
Wenn Leute hier ins Gefängnis,
in die Kiste, in den Knast kommen,
wie man so sagt: Was ist Ihre
Aufgabe? Was machen Sie mit ihnen?
Das Strafgesetzbuch sagt klar, dass
wir sie sicher unterbringen müssen.
Sie dürfen nicht entweichen
oder flüchten können.
Aber der Strafvollzug
muss noch etwas Zweites können:
Er muss sie sicher machen
für nach dem Vollzug.
Was ist das Ziel des Strafvollzugs?
Ist es das Strafen
oder die Wiedereingliederung
in die Gesellschaft?
Es ist von Anfang an
die Wiedereingliederung.
Der Richter
hat eine Strafe ausgesprochen
und wir führen die durch.
Aber immer mit der Perspektive,
dass er wieder ein freier und
verlässlicher Bürger werden muss.
Begegnet man den Menschen hier drin
sonst irgendwo -
sieht man Tätern an,
dass sie Täter sind?
Nie.
- Nie?- Nie.
Das sind Menschen wie Sie und ich,
wenn man sich begegnet.
Sie können aber in gewissen
Situationen ganz anders handeln,
als Sie und ich das tun würden.
- Mhm.
Der Jüngste hier drin ist 19,
also noch sehr jung.
Aber strafmündig ist man
in der Schweiz ja schon viel früher.
Ab zehn ist man strafmündig,
ist dann noch
dem Jugendstrafgesetz unterstellt.
Jene, die für die Umsetzung des Ju-
gendstrafrechts verantwortlich sind,
sind die sog. Jugendanwälte.
* Ungemütliche Klänge *
Ein 14-jähriger Drogenkonsument
wartet auf das Verhör.
Grüezi miteinander.
- Grüezi.
Hoi.
Du kannst mit mir mitkommen.
Ja.
- Hier nach vorne.
Wenn Jugendliche hierherkommen,
haben sie eine gewisse Vorstellung
und machen sich ein Konzept davon,
wie sie sich verhalten.
In meiner Erfahrung
sind sie so überrascht darüber,
wie der aussieht, der dasitzt,
dass dieses Konzept bachab geht.
Ich will sie echt hier haben.
Ich überrasche sie
und so sind sie dann echt hier.
Du hast im März gesagt,
du würdest seit rund zwei Jahren
Marihuana konsumieren.
Wie oft konsumierst du jetzt
ungefähr?
Am Wochenende ab und zu. So.
Von der Strafe her
spielt das keine Rolle.
Ich will einfach mit dir
über das Thema sprechen.
Dann bin ich ehrlich:
Ich kiffe fast jeden Tag.- Eben.
Vielleicht ist es sein Aussehen,
vielleicht
seine verständnisvolle Art:
Hansueli Gürber
gewinnt schnell das Vertrauen
von jugendlichen Tätern.
Über 2'500
sassen ihm schon gegenüber.
Was für ein Schüler
bist du von der Leistung her?
Ein Minimalist.
Warum machst du nicht mehr?
Hm ... Wieso nicht?
Keine Lust.
Wie steht es mit Alkohol?
Jetzt darf ich wohl
zwei Jahre nichts mehr trinken.
Das ist schon mühsam,
wenn man so jung ist.- Ja.
Wann musst du schlagen?
- Wenn jemand mich angreift.
Wie angreift?
- Wenn einer zuerst schlägt.
Als Jugendanwalt
befragt er schon seit bald 30 Jahren
minderjährige Sünder.
Gürber fällt auch Urteile
und ordnet Massnahmen an.
Bewusst
spricht er von "seinen" Jugendlichen.
Weil er sie gernhat
und ihnen Perspektiven geben möchte.
Wenn du eine Lehre machen willst,
musst du dich jetzt anstrengen.
Wurden Sie als Junger
auch mal straffällig?
Ja, auch.
Ich finde das auch noch wichtig ...
... wenn man diesen Job hat.
Dass man das kennt.
Was hatten Sie auf dem Kerbholz?
- Ich habe mal ...
... in einer gewissen Situation
im Ausland ...
... mit der Handballmannschaft,
die über eine Stadt frustriert war,
Kleider geklaut.
Wer sich im Büro umsieht,
entdeckt Hinweise auf seine Person.
Zeichen eines Abenteurers
und Individualisten.
Hansueli Gürber ist ein Mensch,
der sich gegen
gesellschaftliche Normen stellt -
im Beruf und privat.
Also, dann haben wir das.
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Hansueli Gürber studierte Jura,
arbeitete danach
als Gerichtssekretär, Staatsanwalt,
Bezirksrichter
und leitender Jugendanwalt.
Lange Zeit engagierte er sich
auch in der Regionalpolitik
als SP-Mitglied.
Der 62-Jährige schont sich kaum,
trotz Herzproblemen
und Bypassoperation.
Leben und Tod waren für mich
schon immer sehr nahe zusammen.
Ich bin mir sehr bewusst, dass der
Übergang je nachdem schnell geht.
Ich bin ja viel auf dem Motorrad.
Dann weiss man das.
Werden Sie noch längere Zeit rauchen?
- Ich hoffe nicht.
Ich wollte heute damit aufhören.
Ich rauche noch das Paket fertig.
Ernsthaft?
- Ernsthaft. Ja, ja.
Ja, das ist der siebte Versuch.
Heute habe ich
eigentlich ein gutes Gefühl,
dass ich wieder mal
eine Chance hätte.
Die heutige Fahrt führt den
62-Jährigen zu einem Jugendlichen,
dessen Strafregister
ganze Ordner füllt.
* Lateinamerikanischer Pop *
Um diesen 17-Jährigen geht es.
Nennen wir ihn Carlos.
Mit neun
verübte er seine erste Straftat:
eine Sachbeschädigung.
Es folgten viele weitere Delikte
wie Raub, Gewalt,
Drohung, Waffenbesitz, Drogenkonsum,
um nur einige zu nennen.
Vor zwei Jahren
verletzte er mit einem Messer
einen Jugendlichen schwer.
Dieser
überlebte nur dank grossem Glück.
Ja, das war ein ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Ich nahm früher viele Drogen.
Ich kiffte und ...
Ich hatte ein Messer dabei und sah,
dass mich zwei provozierten.
Und dann nahm ich das Messer hervor
und dachte,
sie würden Angst kriegen.
Dass sie weggehen würden.
Aber die Person hatte keine Angst.
Dann schlug er mich.
Und ich hatte das Messer
schon in der Hand
und machte das. Und dann ... Ja ...
Das war
einer meiner grössten Fehler.
Ja.
Bei Shemsi Beqiri, dem
zehnfachen Weltmeister im Thaiboxen,
darf Carlos mit dem Segen
des Jugendanwaltes trainieren.
Dass der 17-Jährige
durch die erlernte Kampftechnik
noch unberechenbarer wird,
verneint Hansueli Gürber.
Bei jedem Kontrollbesuch
stelle er fest,
dass Carlos
sich zum Positiven entwickle.
Der Mensch sei veränderbar,
ganz besonders der junge.
Ihn einfach wegzusperren,
findet Gürber realitätsfremd.
Das Jugendstrafrecht hat den Gedan-
ken der Integration und Erziehung.
Das erreicht man nicht nur
durch Repression.
Die braucht es auch,
aber danach muss etwas anderes,
etwas Konstruktives kommen,
das die Leute
auf das Leben vorbereitet.
Der Fall Carlos führte
zu einem Skandal sondergleichen.
Darüber spreche ich jetzt
mit Hansueli Gürber.
Ich möchte von ihm wissen,
was man machen kann,
um jugendliche Straftäter wieder
auf den richtigen Weg zurückzuführen.
Hansueli Gürber, nach dem Fall Carlos
liessen Sie sich frühpensionieren.
Wie geht es Ihnen heute?
- Ja, eigentlich blendend.
Es geht mir sehr gut.
Ich habe auch noch
eine grosse Familie.
Verfolgt Sie der Fall Carlos
bis heute oder nicht?
Ja, ich meine, der kommt mir
schon immer wieder in den Sinn.
Äh ... Das ist ja ...
Das lief 13 Monate lang
eigentlich ...
... sehr gut.
Dass das danach abgebrochen wurde,
ist einerseits klar mein Fehler ...
... aber andererseits hatte ich Vor-
gesetzte, die kein Rückgrat hatten.
Klare Worte. Über den speziellen Fall
sprechen wir noch.
Eigentlich
war das für Sie als Jugendanwalt
der extremste mögliche Fall.
Mit welchen Fällen
hatten Sie sonst im Alltag zu tun?
Ein grosser Teil der Fälle
waren wirklich Bagatellsachen.
Wir machen ja
sämtliche Übertretungen.
Die meisten Fälle waren so etwas.
Z.B. einmaliger Ladendiebstahl.
Mit etwas Erfahrung
merkte man da relativ schnell,
wenn der oder die Jugendliche
reinkam,
dass die okay sind.
- Ah wirklich? Sieht man ...
Einfach an der ganzen Art.
Sie hatten Angst
und waren sehr erleichtert darüber,
dass sie danach
nicht vorbestraft sind.
Gerade vor einer Woche
kamen die neuen Zahlen
der Jugendkriminalstatistik
von Zürich raus.
Daran sieht man,
dass die Jugendkriminalität
zum sechsten Mal in Folge raufging.
Gewaltdelikte
sind um über 10 % gestiegen.
Kommt da ein Problem
auf uns als Gesellschaft zu?
Ich würde sagen,
dass wir das schon lange haben.
Wir haben heute natürlich ...
Also, nicht heute ...
V.a. Gewaltdelikte
nahmen schon vor 20 Jahren zu.
Ich glaube, das kriegen wir auch
nicht so einfach in den Griff.
Was macht man dagegen?
Gerade gegen die Zunahme der Gewalt?
Wenn jemand das mit 13 macht,
ist die Chance ja auch gross,
dass er das mit 15, 20 oder 25
noch mal macht.
Ja, das ist so.
Einerseits muss man
natürlich mit Sanktionen arbeiten.
Aber man muss das Problem auch
mit den Jugendlichen besprechen.
Oder sogar Fachpersonen aufbieten.
Sie sollen sich mit dem Thema
auseinandersetzen müssen.
Es kommt auch immer darauf an,
wie sie sonst im Leben stehen.
Sehr hart sind die Jugendlichen,
für die man selbst im Moment
irgendwie keine Perspektive sieht.
Gibt es die?
- Ja.
Das ist für mich auch der zentrale
Grund für Jugenddelinquenz:
Sie haben einfach das Gefühl,
die grossen Loser zu sein.
Also muss man v.a. daran arbeiten
und Perspektiven aufzeigen.
Damit der Jugendliche findet: "Doch,
dafür reisse ich mich zusammen."
"Das ist ein Ziel,
das ich erreichen möchte."
Das kann wahrscheinlich
je nach Jugendlichem
sehr unterschiedlich aussehen.
Aber dass es so aussieht
wie im Fall Carlos -
der eigentlich Brian heisst ...
Da kam man am Schluss
zu einem Sondersetting,
was ja fast
ein geflügeltes Wort wurde.
Aber das ist schon eher die Ausnahme.
Dieses Sondersetting zeigte
Hanspeter Bäni 2013 in seinem Film.
So kriegte die Öffentlichkeit
damals zu sehen, wie so etwas läuft.
Wir schauen noch mal rein.
29'000 Fr. pro Monat -
das ist viel Geld.
Aber der Aufwand ist gross.
Rund zehn Personen
kümmern sich laufend um Carlos.
Er hat eine persönliche Betreuerin.
Ich mache Ingwertee.
- Nein, ich mache gerade Wasser.
Du bist seit einem Monat erkältet.
Ist schon gut.
- Das tut dir gut.
Okay, ist gut. Danke.
- Bitte.
Die gebürtige Iranerin
ist eine Art Ersatzmutter
und rund um die Uhr für Carlos da.
Für ihn, der nie
ein geregeltes Familienleben hatte,
ist es wichtig,
eine Bezugsperson zu haben.
Die beiden kannten sich vorher nicht.
Die Jugendanwaltschaft
bezahlt die 4-1/2-Zimmerwohnung.
Sie ist seit einigen Monaten
das gemeinsame Zuhause der beiden.
Wie funktioniert euer Zusammenleben?
Geht das gut?
Eigentlich schon, ja.
Eigentlich gut. Meistens.
Es kann nicht immer perfekt laufen.
Das ist unmöglich.- Wirklich gut.
Er macht grosse Schritte vorwärts.
Es ist nicht einfach,
aber er macht das sehr gut.
Hansueli Gürber hat alle Beteiligten,
die mit Carlos zu tun haben,
zu einem Standortgespräch aufgeboten.
Man staunt
über die stattliche Gruppe,
die sich hier versammelt.
Sein Verteidiger ist da.
Dazu drei Personen
aus dem Sozialbereich.
Weiter Carlos' Sporttrainer
und der Privatlehrer.
Nicht dabei ist Carlos' Mutter,
eine Brasilianerin.
Dafür ist sein Vater gekommen.
(Gürber) Was machen Sie mit ihm?
Wir gehen manchmal in die Stadt
oder vielleicht mal ins Kino.
Wie häufig kommen Sie hierher?
(Carlos) Jedes Wochenende.
- Immer Freitag bis Sonntag.
Am Sonntag gehen wir wieder.
- Das ist toll.
Ja, das ist toll. Und ja ...
Das ist auch wichtig.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Wir machen auch sonst ab und zu was.
Was wir in den letzten Monaten
gemacht haben,
wäre vor einem Jahr
schlichtweg undenkbar gewesen.
Aber zu viel Lob ist auch nicht gut.
- Nein, nein.
Es geht noch weiter. Darum kriegst
du nicht sofort alle Freiheiten.
Wir behalten dich im Griff.
Wir haben uns überlegt,
ob es nicht etwas gäbe -
das haben wir auch mit dir
schon mal diskutiert ...
... mit dem wir Brian
mitnehmen können.
Und zwar in eine Richtung, in der er
eine Ausbildung machen könnte.
Eine Möglichkeit wäre,
dich zum Fitnesstrainer auszubilden.
Das ist eine Überlegung,
die wir zusammen diskutiert haben.
Das macht Stress. Ehrlich gesagt
will ich einfach mehr trainieren.
Ich bin noch nicht gut.
Ich will immer mehr trainieren.
(Beqiri)
Ich habe auch eine Lehre gemacht.
Ich arbeitete 8-9 Std.
und machte meine Karriere weiter.
Ich weiss, dass du das auch kannst.
- Nein.
100 %.
- Ich kann nicht 8 Std. und ...
Du hast nur abends trainiert.
Wie soll ich da morgens trainieren?
Das reicht,
wenn du abends richtig trainierst.
Vielleicht gibt es Zeiten ...
Ich sage irgendetwas:
Du hast eine Verletzung
und kannst nicht trainieren.
Dann könntest du wenigstens mal
irgendwo schnuppern gehen.
Dann bist du mal drin,
siehst das und kannst dann sagen,
dass du es dir vorstellen kannst
oder es dir nicht passt.
Ja.
- Damit du nicht ...
... nur mit dem Blick
auf eine Sache lospreschst.
Schau mal,
was es sonst noch so gibt.
Ja, das ist gut.
- So etwas.
Damit du selbst
zu einer Überzeugung kommst,
dass du etwas möchtest.
Damit du das auch kennst.
Carlos will Thaibox-Profi werden.
Alles andere interessiert ihn nicht.
Einzig die Mitarbeit im
Fitnesszentrum ist für ihn Pflicht.
Sonst dürfe er nicht mehr
weitertrainieren, sagt Gürber.
Mehr Druck
macht der Jugendanwalt nicht.
Auch wenn er sich damit dem Vorwurf
aussetzt, Kuscheljustiz zu betreiben.
Der Fall Carlos erhitzt seit Tagen
die Gemüter bis hin zum Siedepunkt.
Das sog. Sondersetting
führt zu einem Sturm der Entrüstung.
Carlos hat
beinahe jemanden umgebracht
und wird dafür noch belohnt:
für 29'000 Fr. pro Monat.
Gürbers Vorgesetzte,
der Oberjugendanwalt Marcel Riesen
und Regierungsrat Martin Graf,
gehen auf Distanz.
Ich hätte einen solchen Vertrag
nie unterschrieben.
Jedenfalls
nicht mit diesen Kostenpositionen.
Ich orte hier Kritiklosigkeit
und fehlendes Fingerspitzengefühl.
Gürber wird als schrulliger Irrläufer
hingestellt.
Sein Sondersetting wird
unter dem medialen Druck abgebrochen.
Carlos wird wieder kriminell
und beschäftigt die Justiz bis heute,
inzwischen als Erwachsener.
Mit welchen Gefühlen schauen Sie
heute auf den Film zurück?
Ja, da gibt es zwei Dinge:
Dass ich dumm genug war,
den Film zu machen.
Mit ihm.
Also,
Sie sagen, Sie seien selber schuld.
Dass Sie "dumm" waren.
Bis an den Punkt
war ich selbst schuld, keine Frage.
Im Nachhinein ...
- Ich würde es nicht mehr machen.
Sie würden so einen Fall
nicht mehr öffentlich zeigen.- Nein.
Das war ganz klar falsch.
Das war mein grosser Fehler.
- Mhm.
Das Zweite war ...
Das war ja verrückt.
Meine vorgesetzte Stelle ...
... hat Regierungsrat Graf offenbar
gesagt, sie kenne den Fall nicht.
Dass man so etwas sagen könnte,
auf die Idee kam ich gar nicht.
Das war  d e r  Fall,
den wir alle zwei Monate
bei den Intensivtätersitzungen
besprachen.
Beim ersten Punkt sagen Sie,
das war Ihr Fehler,
aber beim zweiten finden Sie,
dass der Vorgesetzte ...
Wir hätten den Fall
durchtragen können.
Aber Ihr Vorgesetzter
stand nicht hinter Ihnen.
Das ist so der zweite Punkt.
- Ja, ja.
Ja, ja. Also, "nicht hinter mir
gestanden", das ginge ja noch.
Er sagte schlichtweg,
er kenne den Fall nicht.
Und das stimmt nicht.
Das war der Fall,
den die meisten ...
Der bekannteste Fall
innerhalb der Jugendanwaltschaft.
Gürbers damaliger Chef,
Oberjugendanwalt Marcel Riesen,
lässt ausrichten:
Das Ganze sei in zahlreichen Gremien
und Aufsichtskommissionen
bis ins Detail behandelt worden.
Dem gebe es nichts beizufügen.
Viele Leute sahen dazumal,
dass man für eine Person,
die x-mal delinquent wurde,
29'000 Fr. pro Monat ausgab -
für diese Massnahmen.
Und viele fanden, es sei ein Affront,
so einen, der auf gut Deutsch
nichts auf die Reihe gekriegt hat,
quasi
noch mit Kickboxtraining zu belohnen.
Verstehen Sie das?
- Ja, natürlich.
Diese Kosten sind auch verrückt.
Letztlich ist es die Gesellschaft,
die beantworten muss:
Sind wir dazu bereit
oder sperren wir ihn ein?
Wobei, wenn man sieht,
was er jetzt gekostet hat ...
Da sind 29'000 Fr.
schon fast ein Trinkgeld.
Sie argumentieren, wenn man
früh investiert, rechnet sich das,
weil solche Personen
dann später weniger kosten.
Jeder, der
eine kriminelle Karriere verpasst,
spart der Gesellschaft
unglaublich viel Geld.- Ja.
Die These "einmal Täter,
immer Täter" - was sagen Sie dazu?
Die stimmt sicher nicht.
Gerade bei Jugendlichen.
Wenn einer 35 ist und bis jetzt
von Einbrüchen gelebt hat
und jetzt wieder rauskommt ...
Dann findet er keinen Job ...
Dann wird es schwierig.
Aber die Jugendlichen
haben ihr Leben noch vor sich.
Viele
wurden gerade darum straffällig,
weil sie im Moment
keine Perspektiven für sich sehen.
Es geht darum,
ihnen Perspektiven zu schaffen,
die sie lohnenswert finden.
Die Gesellschaft profitiert
dann auch, wenn das gelingt.
Da stellt sich generell die Frage,
was es bringt, Menschen zu strafen.
Um der Frage nachzugehen,
gingen
meine beiden "Reporter"-Kollegen
Simon Christen und Christof Franzen
in die JVA Pöschwies.
Dort sprachen sie selbst
mit Inhaftierten.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
In der Schweiz im Gefängnis zu sein,
ist kein Weltuntergang.
Mein "Reporter"-Kollege
Christof Franzen und ich
gehen für eine Woche
in die JVA Pöschwies.
Ich bin hinter der Kamera, er davor.
Die Banalität des Bösen.
- Ja.
Aber auch die Komplexität des Bösen.
- Ja, ja.
Ich berichte seit über zehn Jahren
über Justizthemen.
Er ist zum ersten Mal
in einem Schweizer Gefängnis.
Wir wollen herausfinden,
was es bringt, Menschen zu strafen.
Ich wurde zu sechs Jahren
und neun Monaten verurteilt -
wegen bandenmässigem
Einbruchdiebstahl.- Ja.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Ohne Gefängnis
würde Anarchie herrschen.
Strafe muss sein.
Wer Einbrüche oder Morde begeht,
muss dafür bezahlen.
Das System Gefängnis
besteht ja schon seit eh und je.
Früher war es ein Kerker,
jetzt sieht es so aus.
Das ist fast besser.
Auch wenn es wie ein Hotel aussieht,
sitzt man am Ende des Tages
allein in seiner Zelle ...
... und hat viel Zeit
zum Nachdenken.
Zeit, um z.B. darüber nachzudenken,
wieso er
auf die schiefe Bahn geraten ist.
Wieso er seinen Platz
in unserer Gesellschaft
mit 30 Jahren
noch immer nicht gefunden hat.
Wieso er anfing zu stehlen
und schliesslich
zum Serieneinbrecher wurde.
Das Finanzielle war bei mir
ausschlaggebend dafür ...
... warum es so weit kam,
dass ich hier landete.
Ich brauchte Geld.
Ich bin bereit,
fast alles für Geld zu tun.
Ja.
- Geld löst deine Probleme.
Hat man manchmal
ein schlechtes Gewissen?
Ja ... Ich habe vor der Tat
ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Darum achte ich darauf,
dass es keine Verletzte gibt -
keine Geschädigten sozusagen.
Darum wählte ich
diese Art von Kriminalität.
Ich habe keinen 1:1-Kontakt
mit jemand anderem.
Giorgio mit Anfang 20.
Yeah.
- Kurz vor seiner letzten Verhaftung.
# Okay, und ich mache d Auge uf,
gseh nur Scheiss i dem Läbe.
# Probiere durehalte,
doch isch schwer zum Erträge.
# Ich gseh Bluet und Hass
und Träne uf de Strass.
# Ich frög mich immer: "Für was
isch das guet? Säg mer das."
Er begann, sich einen Namen
als Rapper zu machen.
Daneben brach er quasi im Akkord
in Geschäftsliegenschaften ein
und finanzierte sich so
seinen aufwendigen Lebensstil.
# Weisch du wie das isch,
wenn du is Heim gahsch mit drü?
# Dis Läbe isch beschisse
und du chasch gar nüt derfür.
# Riise Hass uf dini Mom,
lebsch dis Läbe ohni Traum.
# Am liebschte würd ich flüge,
so wiit flüge wienich chan.
Yeah.
# Für was isch das guet? Yeah.
Sie sprechen von jemandem,
der mit drei in ein Heim kam
und einen Hass auf seine Mutter hat.
Ist das Ihre Biografie?
- Ja, das ist sie.
Sie kamen mit drei Jahren
in ein Heim?- Genau.
Mit drei Jahren in ein Kinderheim.
Pilgerbrunnen hiess es.
Dann ging ich von Heim zu Heim,
von Pflegefamilie zu Pflegefamilie.
Dann ...
Irgendwann schlug ich
den kriminellen Weg ein.
Anstatt von ...
... Heim zu Heim, ging es
in Geschlossene, in Gefängnisse
oder Jugendstrafanstalten.
Sie kennen nichts anderes.
Mehr oder weniger.
Kann man so sagen.
Ja.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
* Franzen ächzt. *
Ja.
Wie haben Sie sich eingerichtet?
Was ist mit Familienfotos?
- Die sind privat.
Andere Insassen
gehen hier ein und aus.- Ja.
Nicht alle sollten das sehen können.
- Ja.
Ich sehe überall nackte Frauen.
Fehlt das?
Das ist das Einzige, das fehlt.
Ist das so?
- Das ist die Nummer 1, die fehlt.
Vor dem Knast
standen die Frauen Schlange, sagt er.
# Das isch genau das,
wo alli Fraue wänd.
# Mini Seel het brännt,
das isch mis Tempramänt.
# I dem Läbe kriegt me gar nüt,
aber gar nüt me gschänkt.
Er wähnte sich auf der Überholspur:
höher, schneller, weiter.
Ein Leben im Scheinwerferlicht,
ohne Geldsorgen -
alles schien möglich.
- # Das isch Züri, Züri, Züri.
Ist es noch möglich,
einen normalen Job zu bekommen?
Mit dem Leumundszeugnis heutzutage
ist das schwierig.
Selbst für die Migros-Kasse ...
... muss man
ein Leumundszeugnis vorweisen.
Die Möglichkeiten sind klein:
Baustelle, Schwarzarbeit - aber
das ist auch schon wieder illegal.
Es geht immer ...
... weiter und weiter und weiter.
Und wie kommt es zum Schritt
in die Straffälligkeit zurück?
Über ehemalige Freunde?
Wie kommt man da wieder rein?
Früher machte ich in einer Nacht
12'000 Fr.
Und jetzt soll ich mich
für 4'000 bis 4'500 Fr. ...
... einen ganzen Monat
auf dem Bau kaputtarbeiten?
Es gibt so einfache Wege,
um an Geld zu kommen.
Die legalen Wege
sind schwer und steinig.
Gewisse trauen sich,
den entscheidenden Schritt zu machen
und diese rote Linie
zu überschreiten. Und andere nicht.
Er hat diese rote Linie
in der Vergangenheit
immer wieder überschritten.
Haben Strafen
eine abschreckende Wirkung?
Und lässt sich diese Wirkung
mit härteren Strafen steigern?
Diese Fragen gehören
zu den am besten erforschten Themen
der Kriminologie.
Und die Antworten sind klar,
erfahren wir
an der rechtswissenschaftlichen
Fakultät der Universität Fribourg.
Es wäre schön,
wenn es funktionieren würde.
Das wünschen wir uns alle.
Eine Art Gerät, mit dem man
etwas mehr oder weniger strafen
und so das Verhalten steuern könnte.
Das Hauptproblem: Das menschliche
Verhalten ist extrem komplex.
Warum funktioniert das nicht?
Weil ...
... wir Menschen sind.
Wir lesen nicht in Büchern nach,
was passieren könnte.
Wir machen einfach mal.
Das kann man empirisch
sehr gut nachweisen:
Die Menschen
haben keine Rechtskenntnis.
Die meisten wissen nicht,
was passiert.
Sie wissen irgendwie,
dass etwas nicht erlaubt ist.
Normalerweise. Im Bereich
des Kernstrafrechts wissen sie,
dass man Leute
nicht töten, vergewaltigen,
verletzen, einsperren usw. darf.
Aber was genau passiert,
wissen sie nicht.
Ob man für Diebstahl
drei, fünf oder acht Jahre gibt,
hat überhaupt keinen Einfluss.
Ob fünf oder sieben Jahre -
das ist einfach sehr lange.
Das ist wissenschaftlich
nicht umstritten?- Nein.
Die Empirie ist also eindeutig.
Trotzdem sind und bleiben diese
Fragen ein medialer Dauerbrenner.
Pflegen wir hierzulande die
Kuscheljustiz naiv und wirkungslos?
Braucht es tatsächlich mehr Härte
und strengere Gesetze?
Zu teuer, zu milde -
manchmal
brauche es statt Kuscheljustiz
einfach die ganz harte Tour.
Härtere Strafen
sollen jetzt dagegen helfen.
Der Nationalrat
debattiert morgen darüber.
Sie können
politisch Kapital schlagen ...
... ohne Wirkung.
Sie können die Strafen raufsetzen,
das ändert aber nichts.
Wenn ich relativ sicher bin, nicht
entdeckt und verfolgt zu werden,
spielt das keine Rolle.
Entdeckungs-
und Bestrafungswahrscheinlichkeit
sind die zentralen Faktoren.
Was genau passiert,
spielt keine Rolle.
Also wie lange die Strafe ist?
- Genau. Das spielt keine Rolle.
Zentral ist,
dass es überhaupt eine Strafe gibt.
Und zwar schnell.
"Höhere Strafen, also mehr Jahre,
schrecken andere ab."
Ich glaube nicht,
dass das der Fall ist.
Nein.
- Laut dessen, was wir gehört haben.
Logik 1:
Droht man mit härteren Strafen,
werden weniger Leute straffällig,
weil sie Angst vor der Strafe haben.
Und Logik 2: Wenn man die Leute,
die doch straffällig werden,
länger einsperrt,
beeindruckt es sie noch mehr.
Beides stimmt offensichtlich nicht.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob die Politiker, die das fordern,
und die Leute, die das unterstützen,
wirklich an die Abschreckung denken.
Dass man danach
in einem sichereren Land lebe.
Oder ist es
eine emotionale Reaktion:
"Die müssen in den Knast."
"Die wollen wir nicht
in der Gesellschaft."
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ich kam als 19-/20-Jähriger
ohne Plan hier rein.
Früher stahl ich Autos,
fuhr etwas mit ihnen rum
und liess sie dann stehen.
Ich wusste nicht,
was damit anfangen.
Heute hätte ich fünf Kontakte.
Ich könnte das Auto
für gutes Geld verscherbeln.
Sie schleifen die Seriennummer ab,
lackieren es neu ...
... und ab die Post.
Jetzt wäre es einfacher.
- Ja.
Ich habe jetzt viele Kontakte.
Ich könnte an Drogen oder Waffen
kommen - alles wäre jetzt möglich.
Aber natürlich sollte der Weg
als Erstes legal sein.
Ja.
- Das ist klar.
Aus Amateuren können hier drin
also Profiverbrecher werden.
Das Ziel des Strafvollzuges
ist freilich ein anderes:
diese Menschen
auf die Freiheit vorzubereiten.
Und das in einem Umfeld,
das mit der Freiheit
wenig bis nichts zu tun hat.
Um diesem Problem zu begegnen,
erfolgt der Strafvollzug -
wann immer möglich - progressiv:
Von einer geschlossenen Anstalt
geht es irgendwann in eine offene.
Immer mehr Freiräume sollen helfen,
sich schrittweise wieder
in die Gesellschaft einzugliedern.
Giorgio hatte diese Chance auch.
Er bewährte sich allerdings nicht
im offenen Vollzug.
Darum ging es
zurück in die Geschlossenheit.
War eine Lehre nie ein Thema?
- Das kann man hier.
Aber für Sie ...
- Das war keine Option für mich.
Nein.
- Warum nicht?
Weil ...
Das sind B-Lehren,
wie ich das nenne.
Oder Anlehren.
Man kann
nicht Automechaniker lernen,
sondern nur Reifenpraktiker.
- Ja, immerhin.
Und Schreiner
oder Bäcker oder Gärtner?
Ich kann das unter den Umständen
hier drin sowieso nicht durchziehen.
Ich muss mich
auf anderes konzentrieren.- Worauf?
V.a. damit klarzukommen.
Ja.
Ein paar Wochen später.
Wir sind zurück in der JVA Pöschwies.
Wir warten gespannt auf ihn.
* Lachen *
Du bist sieben Jahre hier
und dann ...
Giorgio hat seine Strafe
bis auf den letzten Tag abgesessen.
Heute wird er entlassen.
Morgen.
- Morgen.
Ich kam allein und ich gehe allein,
wie Sie sehen.
Wie fühlt es sich an,
nach sieben Jahren?
War das eine lange Zeit?
Als würde ein riesiger Stein
von meinen Schultern fallen.
Ich fühle mich erleichtert.
Ja.
- Ja.
Gut, gehen wir.
- Auf.
Auch von mir: alles Gute.
- Ihnen auch. Danke schön.
Viel Erfolg draussen.
Hoffentlich läuft es gut.
Auf Nimmerwiedersehen.
- Gut.
Das ist alles.
Mein ganzes Hab und Gut
der letzten sieben Jahre.
Haben Sie die Bilder mitgenommen?
- Nein, keine.- Keine.
Ein Freund
erwartet ihn vor dieser Tür.
Und natürlich auch die Freiheit.
Boah.
Zieh mal die Maske aus, Bro.
Was läuft?
Blick nach vorne, oder?
Ab in die Freiheit, Bro.
- Ab in die Zukunft.
Wie geht es weiter? Wissen Sie das?
Jetzt gehe ich vermutlich
erst mal nach Hause.
Dann schauen wir weiter.
- Wo ist das?
Zu meiner Schwester.
Dann habe ich hier
viele bunte Scheine.
Sehen Sie das?
- Ja.
Das hat mir der Knast gebracht.
Ist das der Lohn?
- Da.
Make it rain.
Investieren Sie das?
- Jetzt wird investiert.
Ja.
Wissen Sie, wie es weitergeht?
Eigentlich nicht.
- Eine Arbeit oder etwas?
Noch nicht.
Ich hoffe, jemand meldet sich
und bietet mir einen Job an.
Ich nehme alles.
- Ja.
Lass uns gehen, Mann.
Weg von diesem dreckigen Ort.
Nie mehr, Mann.
Ich glaube,
wir werden noch von ihm hören.
Musikalisch, hoffe ich.
Es kann ja auch anders kommen.
Ich glaube auch,
das wir noch von ihm hören.
Ja, gut. Gehen wir weiter.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
"Wir werden noch von ihm hören",
sagte Christof Franzen am Schluss.
Es ist ein halbes Jahr her,
seit Giorgio aus dem Gefängnis ist.
Er wohnt hier in Zürich
und hat eine Freundin.
Was sich sonst so in seinem Leben
getan hat, erzählt er uns jetzt.
Weil er noch keine eigene Bleibe hat,
ist Giorgio
bei seiner Freundin untergekommen.
Wie viel von dem Geld, das Sie
Christof Franzen am Schluss zeigten,
ist noch übrig?
- Eigentlich gar nichts mehr.
Was ist damit passiert?
- Ich habe ein Handy gekauft.
Das kostete ungefähr 1'300 Fr.
Ich musste
ein paar Kleider neu kaufen.
Und ... Ja, essen, leben ...
Das war relativ schnell weg.
Wie steht es mit einem Job?
- Bis jetzt habe ich noch nichts.
Welche Erfahrungen macht man da?
Könne Sie Beispiele nennen?
Oder anders gefragt:
Haben Sie sich wirklich beworben
oder dachten Sie,
Sie würden eh nichts kriegen?
Ich habe mich
noch nicht gross beworben.
Ich bin ja auch noch
ziemlich frisch draussen.
Ein halbes Jahr ist noch frisch?
- Ja ...
Ich hatte Glück, weil ich
eine Freundin gefunden habe.
Sie hat mich unterstützt.
Und dann noch ein paar andere Dinge.
Ja.
Ich stelle mir das so vor:
Wenn man rauskommt, versucht man
möglichst schnell, was zu reissen.
Ein Job wäre für mich so das Erste,
das ich versuchen würde.
Mhm.
Da ich schon mal entlassen wurde,
war relativ klar ...
... dass es nicht so einfach wird,
um einen Job zu finden.
Also fand ich,
ich lasse das mal langsam angehen.
Sie hätten in den sieben Jahren ja
eine Ausbildung machen können.
Ja.
- Oder?
Warum ergreift man die Chance nicht,
wenn man sie kriegt?
Ich will momentan
auch gar nicht arbeiten.
Ich konzentriere mich
voll auf die Musik.
Das ist jetzt mein Hauptziel.
- Ja.
Ich bin nicht so der Arbeitstyp.
Ich habe noch nie
von morgens bis abends gearbeitet.
Und ... Ja,
ich stelle mir das schwierig vor.
Aber alle anderen machen das ja auch.
- Ja.
Eben.
Und ich bin ich.
Ich habe keinen inneren Druck,
der mich zum Arbeiten zwingt.
Ja.
- Es geht mir ja auch so gut.
Wie gross ist die Chance ...
... dass Sie wieder kriminell werden?
Jetzt gerade
würde ich sagen "gering".
Ich bin wie zu alt dafür.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
wieder irgendwo einzubrechen ...
... oder an Fassaden hochzuklettern.
Ja ... Irgendwie ...
Ich habe so viel Zeit
dort drin verschwendet.
81 Monate sozusagen verschenkt.
- Mhm.
Für jugendlichen Leichtsinn.
Damals
konnte ich mir nicht vorstellen ...
... wegen ein bisschen Klauen ...
... knapp zehn Jahre
ins Gefängnis zu müssen.
Gut, Sie waren Serientäter.
- Ja.
"Ein bisschen Klauen"
sieht anders aus.
Es fing an
mit ein bisschen Klauen ...
Ich wurde nie in flagranti erwischt.
Darum machte ich es
noch mal und noch mal.
"Dort klappt es, und dort auch."
Ich achtete darauf, niemanden
zu verletzen. Das klappte auch.
Das Geld reichte auch.
Also machte ich weiter,
bis es zu viel war.
Mhm.
Sie haben
einen gewissen Anspruch ans Leben:
Sie wollen ein gutes Leben,
Sie wollen es geniessen,
gute Kleider usw.
Aber Sie verdienen kein Geld.
Den Widerspruch zwischen Anspruch
und Wirklichkeit ...
... gibt es immer noch.
- Ja.
Ich weiss nicht, ob der weggeht.
Ja ...
Ich muss das machen, was ich liebe,
damit ich es durchziehen kann.
Wenn ich es nicht gerne mache,
ist es schwierig.
Wie schnell
sagten Sie Ihrer Freundin,
dass Sie im Gefängnis waren
und was Ihre Geschichte ist?
Sie wusste das eigentlich schon.
Weil ...
... die Dokumentation
über mich schon raus war.
(Frau) Sorry, die Doku
war noch gar nicht draussen.
Das ist jetzt lustig.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Sie hat gerade selber ...
Ich kenne ihn ja von früher.
Das musst du erwähnen.
Also, ich ... Noch mal.
- Erzähl es richtig.
Das war jetzt lustig.
Es kam ein Veto. Sie hört zu.
Sie steht da hinten
und hört die ganze Zeit zu.
Eigentlich müsstest du
bei dem Interview dabei sein.
Warum stehst du dort hinten?
- Sage ich doch.
Willst du dazukommen?
Hallo.
Sie haben gehört, was Giorgio sagt.
Wie war das, als Sie erfuhren,
dass Giorgio
so lange im Gefängnis war?
Wie reagierten Sie?
- Ich kannte ihn schon von früher.
Ich hatte das aber nicht wahr-
genommen, dass er so lange dort war.
Ich hörte einfach,
dass er wieder draussen sei.
Und ich freute mich,
ihn wiederzusehen.
Ja.
Wenn ich Sie so frage:
Sieben Jahre im Gefängnis ...
Was heisst das für Sie?
Ich muss sagen: Man merkt schon,
dass er lange weg war.
Das fällt einem
an Kleinigkeiten auf.
Ja ...
Wie man halt mit anderen umgeht
und mit denen ist.
Er war jetzt sehr lange allein.
Er ist sich daran gewöhnt.
Er musste nur auf sich achten.
Es gab kein Miteinander.
Ich glaube,
dadurch wird man etwas egoistisch.
Das ist auch nachvollziehbar.
Man muss auf sich selber achten.
Das verändert viel in einem drin,
würde ich behaupten.
Mhm.
Haben Sie das Gefühl, dass Giorgio
irgendwann wieder kriminell wird?
Oder hat er das hinter sich gelassen?
- Nein, glaube ich nicht.
Er hat auch keinen Grund dazu.
Es geht uns gut.
Wir leben in der Stadt Zürich.
Ich halte ihn
natürlich auch davon ab.
Wirklich? Wie?
- Auf jeden Fall.
Ich sage ihm,
dass er das nicht nötig habe.
Sie gehen arbeiten,
er sagt, er habe es ja gut,
weil er bei Ihnen wohne.
Sie arbeiten für Ihr Geld.
Finden Sie manchmal:
"Come on, Finger raus."
Ich habe eine abgeschlossene Lehre
als Dentalassistentin.
Ich arbeite aber auch in einer Bar.
Möglichst wenig.
Weil ich
auch nicht so gerne arbeite.
Ich kann das nachvollziehen ...
... wenn er sagt, er möchte nicht in
einem Betrieb für jemanden arbeiten.
Da hat man Ende Monat 5'000 Fr. und
den ganzen Monat durchgearbeitet.
Man steht früh auf
und ist abends zu Hause.
Ich finde, es gibt auch Menschen ...
Es gibt
so viele Stars und Sänger ...
... bekannte Leute ...
Es gibt Leute,
die durch Dummheiten bekannt werden.
Ich finde, er hat das Talent ...
... er hat eine Vorgeschichte -
er hat alles, was man dazu braucht.
Dummheiten hoffentlich nicht.
- Nein ...
Also, auch ein bisschen.
- Um Musiker zu werden ...
Ich finde, er sollte
auf dieser Schiene ein bisschen ...
Ja, er soll schauen,
was sich da so ergibt.
Er hat eh keinen Abschluss.
Wenn er irgendwann arbeiten will,
kann er das noch in zehn Jahren.
Wenn Sie in die Zukunft schauen,
ist das eigentlich das Ziel:
als Musiker durchzustarten.
- Definitiv.
Ich setze alles auf diese Karte.
- Ja.
Ich verfolge das zielstrebig.
Ja.
- Das ist auch nicht so abwegig.
Er hatte auch schon
seinen ersten, kleinen Auftritt.
Bald hat er wieder einen.
Vielleicht hat er Glück
und wird entdeckt.
Man weiss ja nie.
Das kann schnell viral gehen.
Es ist eine Glückssache, aber
das Talent hat er auf jeden Fall.
Wir waren beim ersten Auftritt dabei.
Scorp 808 im Kanton Thurgau.
Simon Christen,
der "Reporter"-Kollege,
hat die beiden begleitet.
Samstagmorgen.
Kurz vor 7.30 Uhr
in Zürich Wipkingen.
Ganz entgegen seinen Gewohnheiten
ist Giorgio
bereits am Vormittag aufgestanden.
Denn er muss
zum Soundcheck in die Ostschweiz.
In einer Badi
im thurgauischen Stettfurt
hat er heute seinen ersten Auftritt.
* Lockere Musik im Hintergrund *
Heute geht es los.
- Sind Sie nervös?
Ja, schon etwas.
Ich stand schon lange nicht mehr
vor so vielen Leuten.
Mal schauen, wie es wird.
Anthony, der ihn nach der Entlassung
aus dem Gefängnis abgeholt hat,
ist vorbeikommen.
Zeit fürs Frühstück, sagt Giorgio.
* Ruhige Musik *
* Er singt mit. *
Das heisst bei ihm:
Zeit für den ersten Joint.
* Lockere Musik *
Ein bisschen stark für den Herren?
- Ja ...
Dude.
Bisher lebte er von seinem Ersparten
und von seiner Freundin und Kollegen.
Jetzt hat er sich
beim Sozialamt angemeldet.
What's up, brother?
Ein Freund fährt ihn zum Auftritt.
Was ist die Erwartung
an den heutigen Tag?
Ein riesiger Auftritt.
Dass wir die Bühne abreissen.
LDP heisst for life.
Wir werden das rocken.
Davon bin ich fest überzeugt.
Mit meiner Crew hinter mir
läuft das.
Ein paar Stunden später
in der Badi Stettfurt.
* Laute Rapmusik *
Den ganzen Tag
treten hier Newcomer auf.
"ZH meets TG"
heisst die Veranstaltung.
Wir sind leider verdammt spät dran.
Wir sind erst um 22 Uhr dran.
- Erst um 22 Uhr?
Mhm.
- Oh.
22.15 Uhr oder so.
Richtiger Leit...
Weisst du, was ich meine?
Dann wird die Bühne abgerissen.
Sie sollen ruhig für uns anheizen.
Wir machen dann den Abriss.
# ... deiner Bitch.
# Gefällt alles da von diesem Depp.
# Dass er bekommt, warum ich
sie nackt bei mir im Bett hab.
Hip-Hop
ist womöglich die einzige Branche,
in der eine kriminelle Vergangenheit
ein Vorteil sein kann:
ein echter Ex-Knacki
unter vielen Möchtegern-Gangstern.
Ich hoffe, dass es
mir Glaubwürdigkeit verschafft,
das sich im Gefängnis war.
Gerade bei dieser Musik
ist es ein Pluspunkt,
wenn man Realness
an den Tag legen kann.
Darum ...
Ich weiss nicht, ob das gesagt wird.
Wenn es gesagt wird, wissen es alle.
Mal schauen.
* Ruhige Rapmusik *
Giorgio musste wegen des Soundchecks
schon am Vormittag vor Ort sein.
Jetzt heisst es warten.
Immerhin winken 200 Fr. Gage.
Erst kurz vor Mitternacht
ist es so weit.
Thurgau.
- Hey.
Was geht?
- Was macht ihr da hinten, Mann?
Ihr enttäuscht uns.
Ihr werdet etwas verpassen.
# Grr. 24/7, Digga,
hab' ich nur noch Beef.
# Jede beschissene Nacht
bleib' ich auf der Street.
# Sieben Jahre Zelle,
aber heute bin ich Peace.
# Du bist nur eine Nutte,
halt' die Fresse, kleine Bitch.
# Ich muss gar nichts sagen
und die Szene eskaliert.
# Du shootest deine Gang
und die Bitches sind schockiert.
# Die Fresse, die polier ich ...
Wieso strafen wir? Wie tun wir es?
Und was bringt es?
Damit befasse sich die Philosophie
seit Jahrhunderten,
sagt Yves Bossart.
Und die Antworten
seien viel komplexer,
als die scheinbar banalen Fragen
es vermuten liessen.
Es heisst ja im Volksmund
"Strafe muss sein".
Aber ist das wirklich so?
Yves Bossart, Philosoph
und Moderator der SRF "Sternstunde".
Es gibt diesen Satz
aus dem Alten Testament:
"Auge um Auge, Zahn um Zahn".
Der fordert eigentlich,
Gleiches mit Gleichem zu vergelten.
Gab es eine Zeit, als das der
geltende Gerechtigkeitsgrundsatz war?
Ja, das ist das sog. Talionsprinzip.
In der Aufklärung bei Immanuel Kant,
aber auch später,
war das das Grundprinzip
und die Rechtfertigung für Strafen.
Es kam etwas ins Ungleichgewicht
und man muss das ausgleichen.
Das bedeutet
"Auge um Auge, Zahn um Zahn".
Wenn ich dir Leid zufüge,
darfst du mir dasselbe zuzufügen.
Genau. Dann ist die Welt
wieder im Lot und alles ist okay.
Du bist sozusagen befreit.
- Was stimmt daran nicht?
Warum macht es das besser,
wenn du noch darunter leidest?
Du schlägst mich,
ich darf dich schlagen
und wir sind even.
- Beide haben eine Beule.
Aber es tut mir immer noch weh
und dir zusätzlich auch.
Wem hilft das?
Wäre es nicht besser,
dafür zu sorgen,
dass es nicht noch mal passiert?
Mit dir zu sprechen,
damit du Schuldgefühle
und Einsicht entwickelst?
Vielleicht auch Täter und Opfer
aufeinander zugehen zu lassen
und versuchen zu verstehen,
warum jemand das gemacht hat.
Damit ich dir verzeihen kann
und meine Rachegefühle weggehen.
Da ist eine ganz andere Dynamik drin
als im Talionsprinzip,
in dem ich zurückschlagen darf
und dann ist wieder gut.
Man hat heute keinen Pranger mehr,
spannt keine Menschen in Räder,
hackt keine Hände mehr ab ...
Das war früher eine opportune Art,
um Menschen zu bestrafen.
Was sagen Strafen
über eine Gesellschaft aus?
Das ist eine grosse Frage.
Es gibt Untersuchungen
des französischen Philosophen
und Historikers Michel Foucault:
"Überwachen und Strafen".
Er hat über verschiedene
Jahrhunderte untersucht,
wie sich das Strafsystem veränderte.
Ganz einfach kann man sagen,
dass es von der Abschreckung
zur Prävention geht.
Es ist nicht mehr so grausam.
Es wird
stärker psychologisch gearbeitet,
also auch pathologisiert.
Man sieht das ja nicht.
Die Strafformen
werden nicht ausgehängt.
Gefängnisse sind sehr verschlossen.
Man muss viele Hürden durchlaufen,
um einen Einblick zu erhalten.
Es wird marginalisiert
und man achtet mehr auf Prävention
bzw. auf Abschreckung -
aus bekannten, besprochenen Gründen.
Es gibt aber trotzdem
eine Tendenz in der Bevölkerung ...
Gewissen fehlt es,
Strafen auch wirklich zu sehen.
Daher kommt das Wort Kuscheljustiz.
Im Sinne von "Sie haben schöne Zellen
mit einem Fernseher
und sie kriegen sogar Therapie,
die der Staat bezahlt."
Ist das die Auswirkung davon,
dass dieses Rachebedürfnis
in uns drinsteckt?- Ja.
Psychologisch
kann man das genau so erklären.
Wenn ich mir vorstelle,
dass ein Täter sich an meiner
sechsjährigen Tochter vergreift -
da passieren Sachen
in einem drin ...
Da braucht es so viel, um zu sagen:
"Ich wünsche dem nicht den Tod."
Und: "Die Person
hat eine zweite Chance verdient."
Aber das sind
Grundrechte unseres Staates.
Die haben wir in der Aufklärung
hart erkämpft.
Es geht dabei um die Menschenrechte
und Menschenwürde.
Diese hat jeder verdient.
Aber es ist so schwierig,
den Konflikt dann auszuhalten.
Also
psychologisch betroffen zu sein,
dieses Rachebedürfnis zu verspüren,
das tief in uns drin ist,
aber gleichzeitig zu wissen,
dass es schlussendlich
um Gerechtigkeit
und Menschenwürde geht.
Yves Bossart, es gibt aber Menschen,
die Täter bleiben,
egal, wie man sie bestraft.
Einer davon war
der notorische Betrüger Josef Jakob.
Unser "Reporter"-Kollege Hanspeter
Bäni begleitete ihn bis zum Schluss.
Diese Geschichte endet in einem
Gemeinschaftsgrab in der Ostschweiz.
Und so fängt sie an:
in der Strafanstalt Saxerriet
im Kanton St. Gallen.
Hier verbüsste
der damals 57-jährige Josef Jakob
eine Freiheitsstrafe, weil er Geld
veruntreute und Urkunden fälschte.
Seine Opfer: v.a. Kleinanleger.
Tut Ihnen das nicht leid,
dass Sie Kleinanleger ...
Doch, schon,
aber andererseits muss ich sagen ...
Ich will mich nicht rechtfertigen
oder entschuldigen, aber ...
Wenn Ihnen die Bank
ein ganzes Anlagenpapier verkauft -
versuchen Sie mal,
eine Bank anzuzeigen.
Austrittsgespräch
mit der Leitung der Strafanstalt.
Gefängnisdirektor Martin Vinzens
will, dass Jakob flügge wird.
Es geht noch eine Woche oder einen
Monat, bis Sie entlassen werden.
Wir müssen einschränken und schauen,
wie es für Sie weitergeht.
Wir können Sie nicht hierbehalten.
- Das ist mir schon klar.
Dass Sie mich nicht behalten können.
Aber dann
kommen genau solche Gedanken.
Hier drin habe ich
ein einigermassen geregeltes Leben.
Ich habe drei warme Mahlzeiten,
ein warmes Bett,
ich kann fernsehen,
Stereoanlage hören,
ich kann jassen, Kicker spielen,
zwischendurch in den Urlaub ...
... und kriege erst noch
250 Fr. Taschengeld.
Das habe ich draussen eigentlich ...
Das ist traurig,
aber das habe ich draussen nicht.
So, wir haben alles.
Herr Jakob ...- Ich sage nicht:
"Bis zum nächsten Mal."
Machen Sie es gut.
- Ja, ich gebe mir Mühe.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Sieben Monate nach seiner Entlassung
steigt Jakob
erneut ins Finanzgeschäft ein.
So sieht das aus.
Das müssen wir alles renovieren.
Die Scheiben ersetzen.
Hier kommt der offizielle Empfang.
Da gibt es vier Arbeitsplätze
für die Immobilienverwaltung.
Die Firma wird also ...
... immer grösser.
Ja, die ist nicht so klein,
wie man meint.
Das ist im Grunde genommen
das Empfangsbüro
der Managementabteilung.
Und genau das Gleiche,
das ist aber geschlossen ...
... weil es noch
ausgebaut werden muss ...
Das ist dann
die Abteilung Immobilien.
Jakob kann überzeugend auftreten
und versteht es,
Menschen zu manipulieren.
Nun nennt er sich Vermögensverwalter.
Das Startkapital stamme von Leuten,
die im Hintergrund bleiben wollen,
behauptet er.
Josef Jakob ist also
wieder in jener Branche tätig,
in der er früher kriminell wurde.
Ich habe in dem Business ...
Das ist mein Beruf.
Das ist mein Können.
Jetzt müsst ihr euch
einfach mal klarmachen,
dass ich zu den Spitzenleuten
im Management gehöre.
Und in der Betriebswirtschaft.
Hä?
Ich bin kein Laie.
Ich bin kein Trottel.
Und einer ...
- Ich bin maximal ein Betrüger.
Aber sicher kein Trottel und Idiot.
Wie meinen Sie das, Betrüger?
- Hä?
Dafür wurde ich ja verurteilt.
Ist das definitiv Vergangenheit?
- Das ist definitiv Vergangenheit.
Da legen Sie die Hand ins Feuer?
- Sicher.
Hoffentlich verbrenne ich sie nicht.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Seit drei Monaten ist Josef Jakob
wieder geschäftlich aktiv.
Dann kommt dieser Mann ins Spiel,
den wir Bruno S. nennen.
S. wurde auf ein verlockendes Inserat
aufmerksam, das von Jakob stammte.
Er suche einen Geschäftspartner,
schrieb der vorbestrafte Betrüger.
Mit einem Darlehen von 20'000 Fr.
könne man sofort einsteigen.
S. bezahlte.
Später stellte er fest, dass
die Firma gar nie gegründet wurde.
Bruno S.
will nun gerichtlich vorgehen.
Sind das die Unterlagen,
die der Grund für die Anklage sind?
Genau.
- Könnten Sie das Dokument zeigen,
das er Ihnen ausgestellt hat und
mit dem er Sie betrogen haben soll?
Er hat ein Aktienzertifikat
für die Firma ausgestellt,
die er gründen wollte.
Als Sicherheit für die
Gründungskosten.- Und der Stempel?
Auf den ist er sehr stolz.
Der ist auf jedem Dokument drauf.
So sieht es echter aus.
Das ist nach Ihrem Dafürhalten
alles ein Fake?
Ja. Die Firma
wurde bis heute nicht gegründet.
Wie hoch ist die Schadenssumme,
die Sie jetzt davontragen?
Ich habe 20'000 Fr.
an die Gründungskosten beigesteuert.
Und die sind jetzt versandet.
Kaum im Geschäft und schon
hat er wieder eine Klage am Hals.
Das scheint ihn
aber nicht zu kümmern.
Im Gegenteil: Er werde
nun seinerseits Bruno S. verklagen.
Wegen Rufschädigung.
Jakob hat auch
eine klare Vorstellung davon,
was mit dem Darlehen geschehen soll.
Das Darlehen
bezahle ich nicht zurück.
Er hat mir
einen Schaden angerichtet.
Darum geht es.
Er sagt, das Geld sei verloren.
Er habe Ihnen 20'000 Fr. gegeben.
Jetzt sind Sie wieder an dem Punkt,
dass es um Veruntreuung geht.
Ich kann ein Darlehen
doch nicht veruntreuen.
Erkundigen Sie sich
doch erst mal rechtlich,
was man kann und was nicht,
Herr Bäni.
20'000 Fr. sind weg,
die er jetzt gerne zurückhätte.
Nein, er muss mir jetzt
den Schaden bezahlen.
Im Dezember 2007
wird Josef Jakob verhaftet.
Die Feiertage
verbringt er in einer Zelle
im Untersuchungsrichteramt Gossau.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Bruno S.
hat das Urteil per Post erhalten.
Das Bezirksgericht gibt ihm recht.
Jakob muss das Darlehen
von 20'000 Fr. zurückzahlen
und obendrauf noch einen Monatslohn.
Die Weste trägt er zur Strafe.
Das Bezirksgericht
verurteilte Josef Jakob
zu 500 Std. gemeinnütziger Arbeit.
Zweimal pro Woche
muss er nun im thurgauischen
Rickenbach für Ordnung sorgen.
Was ist Ihre Aufgabe konkret
hier in der Gemeinde?
Das Quartier kontrollieren, schauen,
ob die Strassenlaternen brennen ...
Schauen, ob es Schmierereien hat
an öffentlichem Gut.
Bushäuschen kontrollieren ...
Ja ...
* Er lacht. *
Da hat es manchmal Papier drin.
Es gibt so Leute.
Ein paar Jahre später ist seine Welt
komplett auf den Kopf gestellt.
Josef Jakob hat eine
niederschmetternde Diagnose bekommen:
Nieren- und Blasenkrebs.
So.
Wir müssen alle einmal sterben.
Aber Sie wollen nach wie vor leben,
oder?
Ja, sicher.
Das ist mein Lebenswille.
Herr Bäni, ich sage Ihnen
ganz offen und ehrlich:
trotz der ganzen Dinge und so ...
Wir werden noch den 70. Geburtstag
zusammen feiern.
Todsicher. Unkraut vergeht nicht.
Bäni ...
Ist es nicht traurig, dass das ...
... weder meine Kinder ...
... noch meine Geschwister
interessiert?
Mein Bruder war neben mir.
Er wusste, dass ich
notfallmässig ins Spital gehe.
Er hat die ganze Woche, bis jetzt,
noch nicht angerufen
oder mich besucht oder so.
Das ist doch himmeltraurig.
Er führte viele Menschen an der Nase
herum, selbst nahe Verwandte.
Nun muss er fast allein
mit seinem Schicksal zurechtkommen.
Der Reporter
wird zu seiner einzigen Bezugsperson.
Da mache ich mit.
Träumen Sie noch vom grossen Geld?
- Ja.
Wenn du nicht spielst,
kannst du nicht gewinnen.
Das ist so.
Ein Jahr ist es her, seit man
bei ihm Krebs diagnostiziert hat.
Ich war am Mittwoch im Spital.
Sie haben nichts gefunden,
keine einzige Krebszelle.
Das bedeutet jetzt einfach ...
... dass ich einfach
mehr oder weniger ...
Was müssen Sie?
- Ich muss mehr oder weniger ...
... Chemotherapie weitermachen,
einmal pro Monat.
Also geht es Ihnen
wieder ziemlich gut?
Wenn die Augen nicht wären.
Ich möchte ...
Ich kann nicht mal Zeitung lesen.
- Sie sehen nicht mehr so gut?
(Erbost) Was heisst das?
Ich kann nicht mehr lesen.
Ich kann nichts.
Die Brille kannst du wegwerfen.
Für 1'500 Fr.
Das Älterwerden,
der geringe Status und Einsamkeit
widersprechen
seinem aufgeblähten Selbst.
Ich erhalte tagtäglich Angebote.
Bäni, tagtäglich.
Was für Angebote?- Ich könnte
tagtäglich Millionen verdienen.
Ich habe die Nerven dafür
nicht mehr.
Ich bei mir. Ich für mich selber.
Fertig, Schluss. Aus, Amen.
Ich bin der Meinung,
dass es am besten wäre,
wenn man mich langsam
beerdigen würde.
Er sieht sich in der Opferrolle.
Schau mal.
Hier klingeln sie nur ...
Hier klingeln sie nur,
wenn sie etwas von mir wollen.
Oder?
Die Leute verkehren nur mit mir,
wenn sie etwas Positives
herausholen können.
Wenn Sie Zigaretten oder Geld
kriegen oder sonst was.
Wenn sie sich bei mir
zu Tode fressen können,
wenn sie zu Hause nichts haben.
Sie waren doch auch jahrelang
auf den eigenen Vorteil aus
bei anderen Menschen?
Sicher nicht auf diese Art. Ich zog
ihnen die Kohle aus dem Arsch.
Betrüger
haben ein verzerrtes Selbstbild.
Sie manipulieren andere
und sind Egoisten ohne jede Hemmung.
Kürzlich ist er in eine Wohnung
mit Gartensitzplatz umgezogen.
Doch sein Leben
wird überschattet durch
erneute gesundheitliche Probleme.
Wie ist die Diagnose jetzt?
Der bösartigste ...
... Blasenkrebs, den es gibt.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Nicht nur Blase und Nieren
sind vom Krebs befallen.
Auch in der Prostata und Harnröhre
fanden die Ärzte Ableger.
Dazu hat er noch ein Herzleiden.
Ich mache mir keine Gedanken.
Weil ...
... erstens lebe ich zu gerne
und zweitens vergeht Unkraut nicht.
Schon nur das Beten am Abend:
"Gib mir die Kraft und Gesundheit,
damit ich alles
nach deinem Wunsch erfüllen kann."
"Gib mir Gesundheit, gib mir Kraft."
70 Jahre alt ist er inzwischen.
Geschwächt von seiner Krankheit
möchte Jakob
ein letztes Interview geben.
Wir können das abschliessen.
Der Abschluss ist folgender:
Ich habe mich
um sicher das Zehnfache ...
... gebessert.
Ich mache keine Dummheiten mehr.
Ich hole nichts mehr
in die Ding rein ...
Das Einzige, was ich noch mache,
aber das sage ich nur Ihnen ...
... ist Geld zu sammeln.
Geld sammeln?
- Ja.
Immer wenn bei mir Geld ...
aufs Ding kommt ...
aufs Postfach ...
... geht Jakob ...
* Er keucht. *
... Geld sammeln. Oder?
Sie sind also sparsam?
Was wollen Sie sagen?
- Hä?
Damit gehe ich
über Weihnachten in die Ferien.
Neujahr.
Wohin?
Wohin?- Hä?
- Wohin?- In den Süden.
Dazu wird es nicht mehr kommen.
- An die Wärme.
Das war seine letzte Begegnung
mit dem Reporter.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
* Kirchenglocken *
Und so endet diese Geschichte
in einem Gemeinschaftsgrab
in der Ostschweiz.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Wir sind zurück im Thorberg
in einer Arrestzelle,
zusammen
mit Direktor Hans-Rudolf Schwarz.
Das Beispiel,
das wir vorher gesehen haben -
Josef Jakob war wirklich
ein notorischer Betrüger.
Er widerstand allen Versuchen,
ihn zu resozialisieren.
Kennen Sie andere solche Fälle?
Ich kenne solche Fälle,
die sind aber sehr selten.
Das ist eine Ausnahme.
In aller Regel ist es aus
meiner Erfahrung keine Option,
sein ganzes Leben lang
kriminell zu bleiben.
Die meisten Strafgefangenen hier
wollen etwas anderes.
Sie wollen nicht ewig lügen,
betrügen und sich verstecken.
Ja.
Haben Sie sich überlegt, was Menschen
dazu bringt, kriminell zu werden?
Das ist so unterschiedlich
wie die Lebenswege.
Es gibt Leute, die durch alle
sozialen Maschen gefallen sind.
Sie hatten z.B.
Schwierigkeiten im Elternhaus,
verliessen das, dann brachen sie
die Lehre oder Schule ab,
kamen mit Drogen in Kontakt ...
Dann gibt es Persönlichkeiten,
die einfach denken,
sie könnten 100'000 Fr. pro Monat
verdienen.
Und es gibt auch Leute,
die sich hier illegal aufhalten.
Sie haben kein Einkommen
und kommen so zur Kriminalität.
Und dann gibt es die grosse Palette
der psychischen Krankheiten.
Ja.
Was führt schlussendlich dazu,
dass man einen Weg rausfindet?
Das ist ja häufig das Problem.
Es gibt wie keine Alternativen.
Wann passiert der Wechsel?
Der Strafvollzug
kann da durchaus hilfreich sein.
Man weiss auch,
dass der Strafvollzug wirkt
und man so
aus der Kriminalität rausfindet.
Förderliche Beziehungen
sind aber ebenso wichtig.
Darum ist es wichtig,
dass man Beziehungen,
die bei Gefängniseintritt bestehen,
versucht zu erhalten.
Dazu kommt, dass man
kein kriminelles Umfeld mehr hat.
Das ist sehr schwierig.
Arbeit ist auch sehr wichtig.
Man weiss: Hat jemand
bei der Entlassung keine Arbeit,
ist die Chance relativ hoch,
dass er zurückkommt.
Ja.
Das alles kostet sehr viel Geld.
120'000 Fr. pro Jahr,
um eine Person unterzubringen.
Warum ist das so teuer?
120'000 Fr. ist günstig.
Das kann bis zu 500'000 Fr. kosten -
je nach Therapieangebot
und eventuellen Gesundheitskosten.
Der geschlossenen Vollzug ist teuer.
Für eine solche Zelle rechnet man
beim Bund 800'000 Fr. ein.
Und eine Haftanstalt umfasst
heutzutage 250-300 Plätze.
Nur schon die Erstellungskosten
sind sehr hoch.
Der Betrieb dann auch.
Auf dem Thorberg
haben wir heute zwölf Personen.
Wir betreuen sie nur zu dritt.
Jedes Mal, wenn wir zu ihnen gehen -
sei es fürs Essen, für Arbeit -,
sind immer drei Personen dabei,
die sie begleiten.
Weil sie so gefährlich sind?
Jawohl, weil sie so gefährlich
oder so selbstgefährdet sind.
Sie sagen, es lohne sich, so viel
in die Täter zu "investieren".
Das lohnt sich auf jeden Fall.
Hans-Rudolf Schwarz -
Kriminalität scheint
ein absolutes Männerphänomen zu sein.
Wir sprechen
von sehr wenigen Straftäterinnen.
Warum ist das so?
Es ist noch interessanter:
Es sind immer
zwischen 5 % und 6 % Frauen,
die in der Kriminalität auftauchen.
Das blieb über die Jahrzehnte
immer gleich.
In allen Kulturen,
in den meisten Ländern der Welt.
Daran hat auch die Emanzipation
nichts geändert.
Das finde ich sehr interessant.
Zum Glück, muss man da sagen.
Zum Glück werden nicht mehr Frauen
plötzlich auch kriminell.
Aber warum sind Männer
so viel krimineller als Frauen?
Das als Mann zu beantworten,
ist äusserst schwierig.
Als Frau auch.
- Wahrscheinlich haben Frauen
einen anderen Umgang mit Konflikten.
Und müssen auch nicht immer
einen Porsche Carrera fahren,
um damit anzugeben.
Frauen halten Regeln
generell besser ein.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
schon ein Fakt.
Wo es Täter gibt,
da gibt es auch Opfer.
Diese müssen ihr Trauma
oft allein verarbeiten.
Genau da
setzt die restaurative Justiz an:
Sie führt Täter und Opfer zusammen,
um den Opfern
bei der Verarbeitung zu helfen.
Ich dachte, ich käme
nicht mehr lebendig da raus.
Ich dachte wirklich,
jetzt sei fertig.
Am 15. Januar 1995
wurde die Postangestellte
Elsbeth Gubler überfallen.
Jahrelang leidet sie unter der Tat,
kann nicht vergessen,
was ihr passiert ist.
Kurz vor Schalterschluss dringen hier
drei maskierte Räuber ein,
fesseln Elsbeth Gubler
und andere Angestellte.
Die Räuber
flüchten mit 50'000 Fr. Bargeld.
Der Haupttäter war Ruedi Szabo,
der Mitte der 90er-Jahre
das Zürcher Oberland mit mehreren
Raubüberfällen unsicher machte.
Er erinnert sich.
Ich hatte eine geladene Waffe.
Es waren drei Personen dort:
der Posthalter, der gerade
die Tageseinnahmen zählte,
Frau Gubler und eine Pöstlerin.
Wir bedrohten sie
und sackten das Geld ein.
Ich litt während vieler Jahre
unter Albträumen.
Ich erlebte immer wieder Überfälle.
Ich konnte den Tätern
bis jetzt noch nicht verzeihen.
Ruedi Szabo
kommt für neun Jahre hinter Gitter,
als er nach dem siebten Raubüberfall
gefasst wird.
Im Gefängnis macht er eine Therapie,
lernt, zu seinen Taten zu stehen.
Strafanstalt Lenzburg.
Hier
wird zum ersten Mal in der Schweiz
ein Pilotprojekt durchgeführt:
Hier können die Opfer den Tätern
sagen, wie sie die Tat belastet hat.
Ziel ist es, den Opfern zu helfen,
das Erlebte aufzuarbeiten.
Die Täter sollen lernen,
sich in die Opfer hineinzufühlen.
Ruedi Szabo redet Klartext.
Ihr werdet meine Geschichte hören.
Was ich ausgefressen habe.
Ich werde offen und ehrlich sagen,
was für ein Schwein ich war.
Ich habe Menschen
schwerstens verletzt.
Und dann erzählt Elisabeth Gubler,
was ihr passiert ist.
Am 15. Januar wurden wir überfallen.
Sie fesselten und knebelten uns.
Er hielt mir immer die Pistole
an die Schläfe.
Ich schrie: "Nein!"
Ich bekam Angst.
Bei diesem Projekt geht es darum,
den Opfern eine Stimme zu geben.
In der restaurativen Justiz
sollen Wunden heilen können.
Ich sage oft:
"Mit Namen und Vornamen benennen,
was ich getan habe."
Nicht um den heissen Brei sprechen.
Die Kriminologin Claudia Christen
arbeitete fünf Jahre lang
in chilenischen Gefängnissen
mit Opfern und Tätern zusammen.
Sie möchte,
dass die restaurative Justiz
Teil des Schweizer Strafvollzuges
wird.
Es geht um die Heilung des Opfers
und um die Konfrontation des Täters.
Damit sie sich
ihren Taten stellen müssen
und eine Wiedergutmachung tätigen,
die den Bedürfnissen der Opfer
entspricht.
Die damit geförderte Opferempathie
hilft dabei,
die Rückfallquote zu senken.
Das Opfer
im Mittelpunkt der Strafjustiz.
Ein ganz neuer Ansatz
für die Schweiz.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Wir sind
wieder im Gefängnis Thorberg.
Bei uns
ist Kriminologin Claudia Christen,
die Sie
im Beitrag vorher gesehen haben,
und der Direktor des Thorbergs,
Hans-Rudolf Schwarz.
Hans-Rudolf Schwarz, Sie bringen
Opfer und Täter noch nicht zusammen.
Warum nicht?- Der Kanton Bern
war eigentlich Pionier darin.
In den 90er-Jahren
des letzten Jahrhunderts
führte man das
als Modellversuch durch.
Mit Einbezug des Thorbergs.
Man wertete das aus
und musste dann feststellen,
dass es sehr personalintensiv,
und nicht auf eine grosse Gruppe
von Straftätern übertragbar ist.
Claudia Christen,
eigentlich nicht für die Massen,
das sei eher ein Randphänomen im
Justizvollzug - was sagen Sie dazu?
Wir sagen immer, dass restaurative
Justiz nicht für alle ist.
Es ist nicht das Allerheilmittel.
Es ist sehr wichtig, dass es immer
für beide Seiten freiwillig ist.
Damit es auch
keine falschen Anstösse o.Ä. gibt.
Sie sollen wirklich von sich aus
sagen, dass sie das wollen.
Die Opfer?
- Und die Täter.
Es ist wichtig, dass es für beide
Seiten zu 100 % freiwillig ist.
Dann gibt es natürlich
unterschiedliche Umsetzungsansätze.
Einer
ist der direkte Opfer-Täter-Dialog.
Da treffen das Opfer und der Täter
aufeinander.
Und dann gibt es
restaurative Dialoge in Gruppen.
Da sitzen Gefangene und Opfer
von ähnlichen Verbrechen zusammen,
die aber
nicht direkt in Verbindung stehen.
Das ist natürlich
weniger zeitintensiv.
Das sind Prozesse, die im Gesamten
rund drei Monate in Anspruch nehmen.
Welche Erwartungen haben die Opfer?
Warum macht man das überhaupt?
Oft haben sie extrem viele Fragen.
Z.B. bei Tötungsdelikten
gibt es einfach Dinge,
die die Angehörigen nicht wissen.
Was ist wirklich passiert?
Wie kam es dazu?
Wie lief es genau ab?
Das ist unvorstellbar.
Da sitzt man als Angehöriger
z.B. dem Mörder seiner Schwester
gegenüber.
Will man sich dem aussetzen? Warum?
- Es gibt Leute, die das wollen.
Sie müssen das wissen.
Wie gesagt: Es ist nicht für alle.
Aber für die, die das wünschen
und brauchen, um weiterzugehen,
ist es wichtig,
die Möglichkeit zu haben.
Es kann auch
jederzeit abgebrochen werden.
Beide Parteien können sagen,
sie wollen nicht mehr.
Welches Bild haben Sie davon?
Ich finde es
ein sehr interessantes Modell.
Aber man muss auch sehen: Wir machen
ja nicht nichts im Justizvollzug.
Seit 2007 ist die Tatbearbeitung
ein Muss für jeden Straftäter.
D.h.,
dass man zusammen mit dem Täter
sein Umfeld und seine persönliche
Situation vor der Tat betrachtet.
Man betrachtet die Tat, das Delikt.
Man betrachtet das Vor-
und das Nachtatverhalten.
Immer mit dem Ziel, alternative
Handlungen zur Verfügung zu haben,
sollte man wieder
in die gleiche Situation kommen.
Ja.
Wie würden Sie unsere Ausgangsfrage
"Einmal Täter, immer Täter?"
beantworten?
Völlig falsch.
Die absolute Mehrheit
von den Leuten, die hier drin ist,
wird mit uns im Tram sitzen ...
... mit uns einkaufen gehen,
unsere Nachbarn werden ...
... und nicht mehr delinquieren.
Ich spreche dabei von rund 60 %.
Vielen Dank, Hans-Rudolf Schwarz,
und danke vielmals, Claudia Christen.
Nach den Begegnungen in dieser Sendung, bin ich
gespannt, wie es auf euch gewirkt hat.
Findet ihr, dass wir mit Tätern viel zu mild umgehen?
Oder findet ihr, dass es nichts bringt, Menschen einzusperren,
damit sie sich auf irgendeine Art und Weise verbessern?
Schreibt mir eure Meinung und eure Fragen unten in die Kommentarspalte.
Falls ihr die Filme zu den Ausschnitten aus der Reportage schauen möchtet, findet ihr diese hier auf Dok YouTube.